[Music]
still functioning after 11 months of War
Ukraine's Railways are the lifeblood of
the country not only moving people but
emergency supplies and Aid
s
run by this man 39 year old Railway
Chief Alexander kamishen who is
constantly finding imaginative ways to
maintain its functionality in Wartime
here inspecting 50 year old refurbished
diesel trains so can you tell me the
significance of these trains
these trains are appeared in the last
two months it's important for us because
we have to bring new lockers back to
life until we can procure new ones yeah
why would a pair of diesel lockers
because once they switch the electricity
off we have to keep running
Alexander took on this role six months
before Russia invaded Ukraine in
February
since then Railway stations have been a
place of Refuge for many
[Music]
but also a Target
[Applause]
in one of the deadliest strikes of the
war a Russian missile targeted the
Eastern chromatorsk station killing 60
civilians and wounding more than 110.
the missile shown here emblazoned with a
dark message for the children
Alexander has been a Target too and now
travels with security what is the risk
to your life at the moment
the risk to my life is the same as the
risk to all ukrainians Russians came to
kill us we don't want to die
307 Railway workers have been killed and
665 injured since the war started
the 27 000 kilometer network of track is
worked on by more than 230
000 people who are vulnerable to Russian
attacks Alexander's job involves
traveling the country not only assessing
the lines but monitoring the safety of
his Workforce
which he calls
the second Army of Ukraine
I've got the info
at 5 45.
this info says that
10 planes
295.
are ready to Launch
complaints on another location and six
planes on another locations
and we see how many minutes
that day they were carrying 69 missiles
which were fired into the country
and his job is to keep the trains
running through it all
used Sky News tinypro
back here a domestic homicide review has
found that met police missed
opportunities to protect a woman from
her former husband in the years before
he killed her with a crossbow Santa
Muhammad was eight months pregnant when
the attack happened in 2018 her unborn
son survived her former husband is
serving a life sentence
a 27 year old man who's been in police
custody has been rearrested on suspicion
of being concerned in the commission
preparation or instigation of Acts of
terrorism the man was initially arrested
after he was found with a suspicious
device and a suspected firearm outside a
Leeds Hospital police were called to the
maternity wing of St James's University
hospital yesterday where Army
Specialists put a cordon around parts of
the building
in Bosnia tons of waste including
plastic bottles used tires and fridge
freezers have turned a river known for
its Emerald color into a floating
rubbish dump the Drina river flows
between Montenegro Serbia and Bosnia
waste from poorly regulated Riverside
landfills has accumulated behind a
barrier leaving a vast carpet of
pollution which stretches across the
width of the water